-La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première question va être posée
par monsieur Charles Fournier pour
le groupe écologiste.
- Charles Fournier: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les ministres, mes chers
collègues.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
du Logement.
Hier, à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits de
l'enfant, le gouvernement a
présenté son plan de lutte contre
les violences faites aux enfants.
Parmi ces violences
insupportables, il y en a une qui
se joue tous les jours devant nous
et dans nos villes, celles que
subissent les enfants lorsqu'ils
dorment dans la rue.
Ils s'appellent Zach, Michael,
Hermès, Elisa.
Ils dorment dans la ville de
Tours.
Comme les quelque 3000 enfants
dans notre pays qui ne bénéficient
pas de la protection que nous leur
devons.
C'est insupportable.
Depuis 12 jours, j'accueille
quelques familles dans ma
permanence, transformée
temporairement en centre
d'hébergement d'urgence.
Ce n'est pas plus une solution que
de dormir dans une école.
Mais c'est pour lancer un énième
cri d'alerte.
Dès ce soir, ce sont de nombreux
enfants et leurs familles
appelleront à nouveau le 115 pour
espérer que la rotation leur soit
favorable.
Beaucoup encore seront sans
solution, et c'est insupportable.
"Les hommes politiques ne
connaissent la misère que par les
statistiques."
On ne pleure pas devant les
chiffres.
Cette phrase résonne fort
aujourd'hui.
2800 enfants dormiront dehors ce
soir.
Il manque au moins 10.000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence.
Le logement d'abord, une réponse
pour tout le monde ni une solution
pleinement active.
Les chiffres, ce sont des enfants
en danger, des familles.
Etes-vous prêts à venir sur le
terrain pour regarder la
situation?
Etes-vous prêts à rouvrir la
discussion sur les 10.000 places
d'urgence?
Ne me répondez pas par des
chiffres.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Aurore
Bergé, ministre des Solidarités.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député.
Il y a 2822 enfants qui dorment à
la rue.
C'est donc 2822 de trop qui
dorment à la rue.
Donc il y a ce que nous avons fait
il y a ce que nous devons faire.
Ce que nous avons fait, c'est
préserver l'hébergement d'urgence.
C'est une augmentation
considérable de moyens.
C'est 40% de moyens
supplémentaires depuis 2017.
Il y a ce que nous devons
continuer à faire.
En vérité, aucun parent, aucun
enfant ne souhaite être dans un
hébergement d'urgence.
Ca doit être une solution
temporaire.
C'est là-dessus que la Première
ministre agit, de manière à ce
qu'encore une fois, ce ne soit
qu'une solution temporaire pour
garantir qu'ils aient accès à un
logement pérenne.
C'est ça, notre véritable enjeu.
Pour ceux qui doivent être dans
l'hébergement d'urgence, qui
doivent avoir cette mise à l'abri,
c'est un enjeu majeur qu'est
l'accès à la scolarisation.
Un enfant qui est dans le
mal-logement, parce que
l'hébergement d'urgence n'est pas
pérenne, doit avoir accès à une
scolarité normale.
Ce n'était pas forcément le cas
aujourd'hui.
C'est la question des médiateurs
scolaires, des médiateurs sociaux
pour garantir que la mise à l'abri
ne soit pas de la précarité
supplémentaire, que ce soit une
mise à l'abri sur l'ensemble des
aspects de leur vie.
C'est ce que nous faisons et c'est
comme ça que nous arriverons à
répondre à cette urgence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le député?
- Charles Fournier: Madame la
ministre, merci de votre réponse.
Ce soir encore, des enfants
dormiront dehors et vous ne me
répondez pas.
Cette situation est insupportable.
Elles devraient toutes et tous
nous émouvoir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Madame la ministre?
- Aurore Bergé: Je pense qu'il n'y
a pas un membre du gouvernement ou
un député qui n'ait pas saisi
d'émotion par cette question.
Le sujet n'est pas la surenchère
de l'émotion.
Je suis prêt à venir chez vous
comme je suis prête à aller dans
n'importe quel territoire pour
aller voir ces enfants et ces
familles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Violette
Spillebout pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Violette Spillebout: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre, Yannick
Morez, Saint-Brevin-les-Pins.
Vincent Jeanbrun, Hay-les-Roses.
Ce sont nos maires, nos élus, les
symboles de notre république.
Victimes de violences et
d'attaques indignes parce que les
maires, les élus, sont dévoués.
Ils nous font remonter
régulièrement un sentiment
d'impuissance des élus.
Ils craignent la violence sur leur
mairie, leur permanence, leur
domicile et même envers leurs
familles.
Ils dénoncent la haine en ligne et
les menaces et ils alertent sur ce
qu'ils appellent "La fatigue
républicaine".
Je tiens à leur dire que les
parlementaires sont à leurs côtés.
Nous travaillons au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale sur leur
protection.
Je mène un travail avec Sébastien
Jumel.
Saluons ici l'abnégation des
maires qui méritent le respect de
tous.
Le gouvernement agit avec la mise
en place des référents élus en
préfecture, la création d'une
ligne de suivi psychologique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Un peu de
silence.
- Violette Spillebout: Pour que
demain, aucun citoyen ne craigne
de s'engager dans un mandat, pour
que demain, aucun maire ne soit
menacé et attaqué, pour que
demain, aucune famille ne soit
victime, monsieur le ministre,
comment comptez-vous préserver
l'engagement républicain de nos
élus locaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à M.
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés.
Madame la présidente, madame la
députée Violette Spillebout.
Permettez-moi d'apporter aux
maires la représentation
nationale, le soutien, dans une
société de plus en plus violente.
Vous avez raison, certains ici ont
été maires, ce n'est pas le cas de
tout le monde.
Je veux dire que monsieur le
député Sébastien Jumel et
vous-même, vous apportez sans
doute des réponses.
Sept menaces sur dix sont le fait
d'élus avec des administrés.
Ce sont essentiellement des
outrages et des insultes.
Il y a très peu de violences
physiques et lorsqu'elles
arrivent, elles sont extrêmement
difficiles.
On l'a vu, elles sont extrêmement
graves.
3500 maires sont désormais dans le
dispositif.
Nous avons apporté notre
contribution au travail de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat
pour que ce soient les mêmes
sanctions pour les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique et les élus de
la république.
Le texte sera publié au début de
l'année 2024 pour que les
tribunaux puissent condamner
fermement les attaques contre les
élus.
Nous devons continuer à former les
policiers et les gendarmes.
Les procureurs de la République
rencontrent partout les
sous-préfets, les préfets, les
élus.
Ce qui touche les maires, c'est la
crise de l'autorité de notre
société.
Les violences contre les élus sont
les mêmes que contre les
gendarmes, que contre les
policiers, que contre les
enseignants, que contre les
personnels qui sont
sapeurs-pompiers ou les médecins.
C'est ceux qui représentent la
république.
On devrait tous être d'accord sur
ça.
La mission que vous faites sera
écoutée par le président et la
Première ministre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à M.
Sébastien Jumel pour le groupe
GDR.
- Sébastien Jumel: Merci, madame
la présidente.
40 démissions par mois.
40 démissions par mois et le
sentiment pour les maires de
France que l'Etat les ignore, que
l'Etat les méprise quelquefois.
Un mépris qui se traduit par
l'absence notable du président
Macron à cette rencontre de tous
ceux qui sont le coeur battant de
la république.
Tous les jours, nos élus sont
engagés sur le terrain pour
répondre aux exigences de l'Etat
qui s'accumulent, et trop souvent,
nos élus locaux sont empêchés,
parfois humiliés, souvent
enquiquinés plutôt qu'accompagnés.
Pourtant, ils tiennent la baraque
France.
Ils n'ont pas manqué face aux
crises.
Ils sont restés.
Nos maires ont le moral en berne.
Nous voulons ouvrir à un véhicule
législatif pour répondre aux
urgences.
Nous voulons les protéger face aux
violences.
Depuis trop longtemps, la commune
est attaquée, fragilisée dans son
autonomie financière, malmenée par
un déménagement du territoire
subi.
Attaquer la commune, c'est
attaquer la république.
Défendre la commune, c'est lui
donner les moyens financiers pour
préserver les services publics.
Concrètement, cela passe par le
renforcement des pouvoirs d'agir
du maire, dont l'avis doit compter
pour défendre une classe menacée,
sauver une maternité, aider une
famille ou pour faire face au
problème du logement.
Madame la ministre, le temps n'est
pas au discours.
Comment le gouvernement
envisage-t-il, au-delà des
violences aux élus, de faire
respecter les communes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Sabrina
Agresti-Roubache.
- Sabrina Agresti-Roubache: Merci.
Les maires sont au coeur des
préoccupations du gouvernement.
Ce sont eux qui incarnent la
république, qui mettent en oeuvre
des solutions de terrain.
Ils travaillent tous les jours.
Ce sont les premiers à
expérimenter, adapter et évaluer
les politiques publiques.
La démission d'un maire est
toujours une perte dans les rangs
de ceux qui s'engagent pour
l'intérêt général.
Il est demandé aux préfets de
suivre chacune de ces situations
individuellement.
L'engagement de nos maires est
précieux.
Ils sont en première ligne.
Leurs engagements exceptionnels
méritent une protection
exceptionnelle.
C'est ce que fait le gouvernement
au travers des dispositifs
spécifiques d'un plan national
financier à hauteur de 5 millions
d'euros.
Force de sécurité intérieure,
magistrats, associations, ont été
mobilisés.
Mais il faut aussi donner aux
maires des leviers d'action.
La reconnaissance du travail des
maires, c'est aussi le travail
engagé autour du statut de l'élu.
Vous avez engagé ce travail dans
le cadre d'une mission
parlementaire.
La convention nationale de la
démocratie locale, organisée par
Dominique Faure, qui a vocation à
nourrir les réflexions qui se sont
engagées.
Il y a beaucoup à faire sur ces
sujets pour renforcer le rôle des
maires et leur donner le moyen de
conduire leur mandat dans des
conditions à la hauteur de leur
engagement.
Nous sommes mobilisés, nous sommes
collectivement mobilisés.
Nous pouvons réussir ensemble.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la ministre.
Mes chers collègues, je suis
heureuse de souhaiter en votre nom
la bienvenue à une délégation de
l'Assemblée nationale de
Mauritanie, conduite par le
président du groupe d'amitiés
France-Mauritanie.
Applaudissements
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à M.
Didier Lemaire pour le groupe
Horizons.
- Didier Lemaire: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, chers collègues.
Dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche,
Thomas, 16 ans, est décédé à la
suite de ses blessures dans un
village de la Drôme après une
attaque d'une violence inouïe et
sans motif apparent.
Je veux ici m'associer à la
douleur de ses proches, sa
famille, de ses amis, de son
village.
...
Nous vivons actuellement en
France, dans nos villages, nos
villes, une période de tension
sociale et de repli.
Cette attaque dans un petit
village du sud de la France
ajoutée aux autres difficultés de
nos concitoyens et concitoyens, au
quotidien, participent au climat
anxiogène dans lequel nous
évoluons depuis quelques mois.
Ce climat, c'est aussi celui d'une
violence et une pression toujours
plus importante portée sur les
femmes et les hommes qui
consacrent leur vie
professionnelle, et bien trop
souvent personnelle, au service de
nos concitoyens.
Je pense aux élus, aux
professeurs, policiers, gendarmes,
sapeurs-pompiers, personnel
soignant, celles et ceux qui ont
été cités par mes collègues tout à
l'heure.
La nation a encore enterré un de
ses professeurs il y a quelques
semaines.
Un maire sur deux ne souhaite pas
se représenter en 2026.
Qui va tenir notre nation lorsque
plus personne ne s'engagera dans
le vivre ensemble?
Lorsque ces personnes sont
attaquées, agressées, agacées,
insultées, c'est l'intégrité de
notre démocratie tout entière qui
est touchée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à M.
Eric Dupond-Moretti, garde des
Sceaux, ministre de la Justice.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Monsieur...
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député Didier Lemaire,
vous irez bientôt en vacances vous
aussi.
Monsieur le député...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Allez!
Un peu de silence.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Monsieur le
député Lemaire...
D'abord, je voudrais m'associer
évidemment aux propos de
compassion que vous avez eus à
l'égard de ce gosse qui est mort à
16 ans.
On pense évidemment tous à sa
famille.
Je ne doute pas que certains
tenteront d'exploiter de façon
politicienne ce drame absolu dans
quelques instants.
S'agissant des élus, j'ai demandé
au procureur de la République des
réponses fermes.
Je veux vous annoncer des
chiffres.
En 2022, le taux de réponse pénale
des infractions commises contre
les élus s'élève à 98%, contre 94%
en 2017.
A gravité égale, pour des faits de
violence, le taux d'emprisonnement
ferme est de 51%.
Le taux de déférent est de 51%.
Cela confirme la prise en
considération de la qualité d'élus
par nos juridictions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à M.
Carlos Martens Bilongo pour le
groupe La France Insoumise.
- Carlos Martens Bilongo: Madame
la Première ministre, depuis les
terribles massacres du 7 octobre
2023 perpétrés par le Hamas, nous
condamnons les crimes de guerre
visant à terroriser les
populations civiles israéliennes.
Nous condamnons avec la plus
grande fermeté les crimes de
guerre et la vengeance aveugle de
l'armée israélienne sur le peuple
palestinien.
Le 9 octobre 2023, le ministre
israélien de la défense a déclaré:
"J'ai ordonné un siège complet
dans la bande de Gaza, il n'y aura
pas d'électricité, pas de
nourriture, pas de carburant, tout
est fermé."
"Nous combattons des animaux
humains et nous agissons en
conséquence."
Le Premier ministre Benjamin
Nétanyahou a dit: "Nous ferons de
Gaza une île déserte, nous
viserons chaque recoin de la bande
de Gaza."
Pourtant, la France a accordé un
soutien inconditionnel à Israël.
Depuis 45 jours, voilà le
résultat: la bande de Gaza est
assiégée.
Il y a des bombardements partout.
Plus de 13.000 morts.
Il y a 5500 enfants qui décèdent
dans la bande de Gaza!
Réagissez!
40 à 50% du bâti de la ville sont
complètement détruits.
280 écoles sont détruites.
Le port de Gaza est détruit.
J'aurais une question, madame la
Première ministre.
La France, selon le rapport de
2023, au Parlement, l'exportation
de la France d'armes, outre ses
ventes effectives, la France a
délivré de nombreuses licences
d'exploitation matérielle.
La France continuera-t-elle à
livrer des armes à Israël?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Colonna, ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, je voudrais
vous assurer que la position de la
France ne varie pas.
Israël a subi une attaque
terroriste barbare.
Israël a le droit de se défendre,
comme nous-mêmes nous aurions le
droit de nous défendre.
Des otages sont retenus dans la
bande de Gaza.
Dont des Français.
Nous demandons leur libération
immédiate sans condition.
Je suis sûre que vous pensez aussi
à eux.
Les Palestiniens ne doivent pas
payer pour les crimes du Hamas.
Voilà nos principes.
Voilà des principes justes et
clairs.
Oui, monsieur le député, il y a à
Gaza trop de souffrance.
Et trop de morts.
Nous l'avons dit clairement depuis
plusieurs semaines.
Il faut une trêve immédiate
durable pour que davantage d'aide
entre à Gaza, pour que les
populations civiles soient
protégées et pour que cette trêve
conduise à un cessez-le-feu.
Nous agissons.
C'est ce consensus qui s'est forgé
à Paris le 9 novembre lors de la
conférence humanitaire, et c'est
aussi la position d'un nombre
croissant de nos partenaires.
La France est aussi au rendez-vous
concrètement pour l'aide aux
Palestiniens, soutien aux Nations
Unies, aide médicale, déploiement
d'hélicoptères, possibilité
ouverte pour des enfants
palestiniens de pouvoir être
soignés en France.
Je remercie le ministre de la
Santé.
Voilà du concret.
S'agissant des hôpitaux, ce sont
des sanctuaires.
Ils le sont pour les Israéliens
comme ils le sont pour les
Palestiniens.
Le droit international interdit
formellement de détourner des
hôpitaux à des fins militaires.
Cela se produit.
Quant aux crimes commis par les
colons contre les Palestiniens,
crimes trop nombreux, nous les
condamnons officiellement et
ouvertement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la ministre.
Vous n'avez plus de temps.
Merci.
Monsieur Carlos Martens Bilongo,
vous n'avez que deux secondes.
- Carlos Martens Bilongo:
L'article du TCA interdit la vente
d'armes pour des crimes de guerre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Lisette Pollet pour le
Rassemblement National.
- Lisette Pollet: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Avant de commencer, je voudrais
avoir une pensée pour Thomas,
assassiné dimanche matin.
Je redis mon soutien à ses proches
et à tous les blessés de cette
terrible attaque.
Notre pays est une nouvelle fois
en deuil.
Thomas est décédé à Crépol après
avoir reçu un coup de couteau.
Ce meurtre est le témoignage
criant de l'ensauvagement de notre
société.
Notre ruralité n'est plus épargnée
par la sauvagerie.
Que des viennent faire une razzia
en toute impunité est intolérable.
Si des jeunes agissent comme cela,
c'est qu'il y a un réel problème
de société.
Enzo, Axel, Anthony et maintenant
Thomas.
La liste des enfants de France
tués gratuitement est trop longue.
Autant de familles endeuillées qui
ne comprennent pas que ces
atrocités continuent.
Les mesures pour combattre cet
ensauvagement ne sont pas prises.
Mais cela ne peut plus durer.
La France en a assez de voir ses
enfants mourir.
Les Français ne supportent plus ce
terrorisme du quotidien.
Non, cette mort n'est pas un fait
divers.
Il y a urgence que nous,
politiques, que nous apportions
une réponse pour que les Français
bénéficient de la première des
libertés: la sécurité!
Alors, que comptez-vous faire pour
que cette insécurité dans nos
villes et nos villages cesse?
Ce qui arrive, nous l'avions
prédit.
Les Français souffrent du manque
de fermeté dans la justice.
Ces jeunes n'ont plus peur de tuer
et n'ont plus peur de la police ni
de la justice.
Il est temps que la peur change de
camp...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, ma chère collègue.
La parole est à M.
Gérald Darmanin, ministre de
l'Intérieur.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Permettez-moi également d'adresser
mes condoléances à cette famille
et aussi aux blessés, puisqu'ils
sont trois à l'hôpital, et à leurs
familles.
Evidemment, ce qui s'est passé il
y a quelques heures est absolument
ignoble, inacceptable.
Tous les moyens de la gendarmerie
nationale ont été mis.
Je peux vous annoncer que 7
interpellés ont été faits par la
gendarmerie nationale aux environs
de Toulouse.
L'enquête dira si ce sont les
personnes qui sont les auteurs de
ce crime odieux.
Nous pouvons penser, après ces
auditions, que ces personnes qui
sont accusées par la gendarmerie
nationale, soient inculpées.
Je veux dire que le travail que
nous faisons, policiers et
gendarmes, partout sur le
territoire national, dans les
villes comme dans les campagnes,
est un travail admirable.
Oui, j'ai été le premier à dire
que le travail des policiers et
des gendarmes est un travail
difficile.
Au moment où vous ne connaissez
pas l'âge des interpellés ni leur
nationalité ni comment ça s'est
passé, madame, évitez de rajouter
l'indignité à un drame qui touche
toute la nation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Emmanuelle
Anthoine pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Emmanuelle Anthoine: Ce
week-end, dans la nuit du 18 au 19
novembre, dans ma circonscription,
la vie d'un adolescent de 16 ans a
été emportée.
Thomas a succombé aux coups qui lui
ont été infligés.
Ce jeune avait toute une vie
devant lui.
Il lui restait tout à vivre.
Ses joies, ses amours, ses
espoirs...
Tout cela lui a été enlevé.
Thomas avait une famille, des
parents aimants, des amis proches.
Thomas n'a pas eu droit à une
minute de silence.
Je tiens donc à lui rendre hommage
dans cet hémicycle, temple de
notre république, pour que la
représentation nationale témoigne
unanimement de son soutien envers
sa famille.
Applaudissements
...
Ce week-end, une bande de jeunes a
fait irruption dans un moment
festif pour en découdre.
Lors d'un bal organisé par le
comité des fêtes de la commune de
Crépol, ils ont violemment attaqué
à l'arme blanche les participants
de cette soirée.
16 autres personnes ont été
blessées.
Deux sont en urgence absolue à
l'issue de ce drame.
Je leur adresse tout mon soutien.
Pour tous les jeunes présents, ce
qui devait être un moment de fête
a finalement été le mouroir de
leur insouciance juvénile.
Pour tous les participants, la
convivialité de cet événement a
effroyablement laissé place au
deuil et à la désolation que
partage tout notre territoire.
La violence a encore frappé dans
notre pays.
Cette violence qui ne cesse de
meurtrir et d'endeuiller, cette
violence qui nous gangrène tous et
que l'on ne parvient pas à
enrayer.
Nous devons unanimement la
condamner.
Des familles entières sont
endeuillées.
Nos jeunes doivent pouvoir vivre
leur jeunesse, tout simplement.
Merci beaucoup
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à M.
Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Pour la mesure dont vous avez fait
preuve en posant cette question,
merci.
Oui, la vie enlevée de ce gosse de
16 ans méritait à l'évidence un
moment de silence et de
recueillement.
Il a immédiatement été substitué
par un moment de polémique.
J'ai noté d'ailleurs que dans la
question précédente, on évoquait
le mot de razzia.
Il n'y a pas de hasard.
Il n'y a que des rendez-vous, les
rendez-vous du malheur que vous
honorez, qu'il s'agisse de la
petite Lola, du petit Clément...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Une
dernière chose!
Les auteurs de ces faits seront
jugés par une cour d'assises
composée d'un jury populaire,
comme le sont tous les crimes de
sang, et ce sont des Français
comme vous, comme moi, qui
rendront la justice, qui n'est pas
laxiste, qui est de plus en plus
sévère depuis 20 ans!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
Madame Emmanuelle Anthoine?
- Emmanuelle Anthoine: J'espère
que la justice sera à la hauteur.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la députée.
La parole est à M.
Philippe Fait pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Philippe Fait: Merci.
Merci, madame la présidente.
Le 8 novembre, dans l'Hérault,
Sonia a été mortellement
poignardée à 26 reprises par son
mari.
Le 15 novembre, dans la Somme,
Sonia a été battue à mort par son
compagnon à leur domicile.
C'est aussi Claire, Madison,
Irène, Juliana ainsi que Séverine
ou encore Edith ces six dernières
semaines.
93 femmes ont perdu la vie en
raison de féminicide depuis le
début de l'année.
Je tiens à avoir une pensée pour
chacune d'entre elles.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre Bérangère Couillard.
En 2022, plus de 240.000 personnes
ont été victimes de violences
commises par leur partenaire ou
ex-partenaire, soit une hausse de
plus de 15% par rapport à 2021.
Si ces chiffres restent
inquiétants, ils sont révélateurs
d'une libération verbale, une
prise en compte plus importante de
la parole des femmes.
Les violences sont multiformes.
Un violentomètre à taille humaine
a été créé et inauguré ce midi à
l'Assemblée nationale.
Je vous remercie d'avoir permis
cela.
Cela permet de mesurer les
comportements déviants et si la
relation est basée sur le
consentement et ne porte pas de
violence.
Cette initiative nous invite tous
et toutes à réfléchir sur la
qualité de notre rapport à
l'autre.
Alors que la mobilisation grandit
d'année en année, alors que
l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes a été déclarée grande cause
du quinquennat, les moyens de
lutter contre ce fléau doit être à
la hauteur.
Les Français attendent des actes
forts.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, mon
cher collègue.
La parole est à madame Bérangère
Couillard, ministre chargée de
l'Egalité entre les femmes et les
hommes et de la lutte contre les
discriminations.
- Bérangère Couillard: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député, déjà, je
tenais à vous remercier pour
l'initiative que vous avez lancée
avec les lycéens du lycée Jules
Verne, d'Etables-sur-Mer.
Nous étions ravis de pouvoir
inaugurer cette initiative.
C'est un travail de
sensibilisation indispensable à
mener.
Cela permet de rappeler qu'il
suffit d'une bousculade, d'une
claque, pour que les violences
adviennent.
Nous agissons depuis maintenant
2019 avec le Grenelle des
violences conjugales.
Nous avons mis en place de
nombreux dispositifs.
Le recueil de la parole des
femmes, d'abord, avec l'extension
de la ligne téléphonique 24 heures
sur 24 et sept jours sur sept.
Nous avons formé des policiers et
des gendarmes, 150.000.
Nous avons fait en sorte de
déployer des dispositifs qui
permettent de protéger les femmes.
Ce sont des bracelets
anti-rapprochement, des téléphones.
Nous avons sensiblement augmenté
les places d'hébergement
d'urgence, nous avons multiplié
par deux ces places.
Elles sont au nombre de 10.000.
Nous souhaitons agir sur la
récidive.
Nous avons ouvert 30 centres de
prise en charge de violences
conjugales.
Ils sont accompagnés
psychologiquement, également à la
réinsertion à l'emploi et au
traitement des addictions.
Mais nous ne sommes pas satisfaits
des résultats.
Beaucoup de choses sont encore à
faire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à madame la
vice-présidente Valérie Rabault
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Valérie Rabault: Merci.
Merci, madame la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, je ne sais pas trop à
qui je vais poser la question.
La pénurie de médicaments connaît
un nouveau pic en France, et selon
l'agence nationale de la sécurité
du médicament, il manque
aujourd'hui de l'amoxicilline, des
bêtabloquants et encore beaucoup
d'autres médicaments
indispensables à la vie.
On est passé de 700 médicaments en
pénurie en 2018 à plus de 3700 en
2022.
Vous me direz que tous les pays en
Europe connaissent des
difficultés.
C'est vrai.
Mais la France est le pays qui en
Europe connaît le plus de
difficultés et le plus de pénurie.
Depuis quatre ans, vous avez
annoncé au gouvernement plusieurs
plans qui n'ont eu aucun effet sur
l'approvisionnement en
médicaments.
Vous dites d'un côté vouloir
relocaliser et de l'autre, vous
nous dites absolument rien quand
Sanofi, qui produit 70% du
paracétamol, a annoncé fin octobre
vendre son usine en France.
Vous ne vous êtes absolument pas
soucié de savoir si la production
de paracétamol resterait en
France.
La seule chose que vous faites
dans le budget de la Sécurité
sociale, c'est de mettre des
franchises sur les boîtes de
médicaments que les Français ne
peuvent plus se procurer.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, donnez-moi deux mesures
pour faire en sorte de réduire les
pénuries de médicaments.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à M.
Aurélien Rousseau, ministre de la
Santé et de la Prévention.
- Aurélien Rousseau: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
madame la présidente, nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une situation de
tension sur l'approvisionnement de
certains médicaments, mais qui
n'est pas la même situation que
l'an dernier.
Aujourd'hui, sur le droit
national, notamment après la
saison extrêmement difficile de
l'année dernière, nous avons les
stocks qui permettent, sur les
médicaments que vous avez cités,
nous les avons.
Ce qui se passe aujourd'hui, c'est
une dérégulation complète du
système de distribution.
Il faut mettre les mots sur les
réalités.
Il y a certains acteurs qui
veulent profiter du système pour
s'assurer de la rentabilité.
J'ai réuni tous les acteurs de la
filière du médicament il y a huit
jours.
Demain, je serai en mesure
d'annoncer que les différents
acteurs de la chaîne industrielle,
grossistes, répartiteurs et
pharmaciens, se sont mis d'accord
pour stopper la dérive qui
consistait notamment, pour
certaines pharmacies, à acheter
directement auprès des
industriels, ce qui conduisait à
favoriser les plus grosses
pharmacies par rapport aux petites
pharmacies, notamment les
pharmacies rurales.
Nous reviendrons à une régulation
normale.
Dans le PLFSS, nous proposons
également de renforcer les
compétences de police sanitaire de
l'agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament, pour que précisément,
dans un cas comme celui-ci, nous
ne soyons pas forcément obligés de
passer par la bonne volonté des
acteurs, même avec la pression du
gouvernement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
Madame Valérie Rabault?
- Valérie Rabault: J'ai deux
demandes.
Sur l'obligation de constituer des
stocks de deux à quatre mois, vous
n'avez aucun contrôle.
Il y a eu zéro sanction en 2021 et
trois en 2022 pour 300.000 euros
sur un budget total de 24
milliards d'euros.
Je vous demande de faire appliquer
des sanctions.
Face aux pénuries les plus graves,
je vous demande d'assumer votre
rôle de puissance publique et
d'organiser une production
minimale dans les hôpitaux, ce que
prévoit l'article 32 et que vous
ne mettez pas en oeuvre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, ma
chère collègue.
La parole est à M.
Stéphane Rambaud.
- Stéphane Rambaud: Merci.
Mes propos s'adressent à madame la
ministre chargée des Collectivités
territoriales et de la ruralité.
Alors que s'ouvre à Paris le salon
des maires et des collectivités,
permettez-moi d'aborder deux
problématiques qui impactent
l'avenir de nos démocraties
locales.
Depuis plusieurs années, nous
assistons à une augmentation des
violences envers les élus locaux,
particulièrement les maires.
En 2022, le ministère de
l'Intérieur a signalé une hausse
de 32% de ces violences.
Ces actes allant de l'intimidation
verbale à l'agression physique,
mettent en lumière la
vulnérabilité des élus.
Il n'y a pas de soutien concret du
gouvernement.
Les problèmes financiers aussi
s'accumulent.
Des décisions unilatérales comme
la suppression non compensée de la
taxe d'habitation mettent en péril
les finances des communes.
Dans votre interview au JDD du 19
novembre, vous avez déclaré que
les maires devaient faire des
efforts, mais ils sont déjà
contraints de gérer, avec des
ressources limitées.
Cette situation pèse sur les
épaules des élus.
A cela s'ajoute le retrait
progressif des compétences
essentielles aux communes.
Dans ma circonscription du Var, le
PLU pour construire une clinique a
été mis à l'arrêt par la
métropole, contre le gré de cette
commune et sans l'avoir informée
de cela, alors que le maire avait
lancé la révision.
Ces contraintes, liées à
l'insécurité croissante, ont
conduit à près de 1500 démissions
de maires depuis 2020.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Sabrina
Agresti-Roubache.
- Sabrina Agresti-Roubache: Merci.
Monsieur le député, travailler en
confiance ne veut pas dire être
d'accord sur tout.
Dans ma méthode, dans ce que je
dis à chaque fois, beaucoup de vos
collègues m'interpellent.
Je n'ai jamais hésité à concerter,
écouter et entendre.
C'est la méthode du gouvernement.
Il se concerte avec les élus
locaux.
Le but est de discuter avec celles
et ceux qui incarnent la
République.
Vous me posez une question qui m'a
été posée tout à l'heure au
congrès des maires, où j'ai été
interpellée par un élu qui
m'expliquait que dans sa commune,
telle direction n'avait pas été
prise.
Je lui ai dit: "Sur les sites
éducatifs, si vous estimez que
dans votre commune, ce n'est pas
une bonne mesure à prendre..."
Ce n'est pas une bonne direction,
l'Etat ne peut pas se substituer à
tout.
Vous ne pouvez pas incriminer
l'Etat tout le temps.
La taxe d'habitation a été
compensée, vous le savez.
Je fais partie de ces ministres
qui ont été comme vous sur ces
bancs.
Ma porte est ouverte.
Celle de ma collègue Dominique
Faure aussi, celle du ministre de
l'Intérieur aussi.
Vous savez m'interpeller,
m'écrire, cela peut être utile.
Vous avez systématiquement une
réponse directe.
Jamais je ne me dérobe, et le
gouvernement, encore moins.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Léo
Walter.
- Léo Walter: Merci.
Madame la secrétaire d'Etat à
l'enfance, votre prédécesseur
annonçait la création d'une
commission sur la violence
sexuelle faite à l'enfant, centrée
sur la question de l'inceste.
En janvier 2021, suite à la
parution du livre de Camille
Kouchner, Emmanuel Macron disait
que "le silence enfin explose."
Il explose grâce au courage des
personnes qui témoignent.
Plus personne ne peut ignorer ces
mots et ces cris.
C'est à nous d'agir.
Le 11 mars, la Ciivise était
instaurée avec une feuille de
route.
Près de 30.000 témoignages ont été
recueillis.
J'ai attendu ce moment toute ma
vie.
Pour se confier, il faut avoir
confiance.
La Ciivise a su devenir cette
personne de confiance.
Depuis plusieurs mois,
l'incertitude pèse sur le devenir
de la Ciivise.
Son mandat sera-t-il prolongé?
Sous quelle forme et avec qui à sa
tête?
Aucune annonce officielle n'a
répondu à ces inquiétudes.
Vous avez déclaré il y a trois
jours: "Je souhaite que le travail
de la Ciivise continue avec une
nouvelle feuille de route."
Hier, Journée internationale des
droits de l'enfant, alors que la
Ciivise présentait son rapport, on
n'en savait pas plus.
Confirmez-vous que la Ciivise sera
maintenue?
Avec quelle feuille de route?
Le 23 janvier 2021, Emmanuel
Macron a dit: "On vous écoute, on
vous croit, vous ne serez plus
jamais seuls."
Dimanche, vous avez dit que vous
aviez encore une révolution à
accomplir pour protéger nos
enfants.
Je suis d'accord avec vous.
Est-ce que ces promesses seront
tenues?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Charlotte
Caubel.
- Charlotte Caubel: Merci.
Monsieur le député Léo Walter,
nous l'avons dit et je le répète,
le gouvernement souhaite que le
travail de la Ciivise continue
avec une feuille de route
renouvelée et centrée sur de
nouvelles missions.
Nous en présenterons le détail
avec le garde des Sceaux dans les
prochaines semaines.
Nous avons reçu le rapport de 750
pages et de 82 recommandations
vendredi dernier.
Je comprends votre impatience,
mais il nous faut du temps pour
étudier les choses.
Cette Ciivise, c'est le président
qui l'a voulue.
C'est le président qui l'a
soutenue.
Le gouvernement l'a soutenue et
écoutée.
Hier, nous avons présenté tous
ensemble, à 12 ministres, un plan
audacieux de lutte contre la
violence faite aux enfants, dans
la suite d'un plan qui avait déjà
été conduit depuis 2019.
Enormément de choses ont été
reprises, grâce aux préconisations
de la Ciivise.
Nous avons écouté la Ciivise.
Je suis moins écoutée que la
Ciivise, parce qu'elle a recueilli
des témoignages importants qui
nous ont permis d'évaluer l'impact
de ces violences sur les enfants.
C'est grâce à cela que nous
pouvons porter un combat collectif
qui n'est pas le combat d'un
homme, mais celui d'un
gouvernement, d'un parlement, qui
doit être le combat de tous les
adultes de ce pays pour éradiquer
ce fléau.
Nous présenterons les modalités et
la feuille de route dans quelques
jours.
Je comprends votre impatience.
Ca fait des millénaires que nous
attendons cela.
La révolution est en marche.
Laissez-nous agir avec fermeté.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la
présidente Perrine Goulet.
- Perrine Goulet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
Il est de notre devoir, en tant
que société, de veiller à la
protection de nos enfants.
Ils sont les piliers de notre
avenir.
Votre ministère et ses agents
jouent chaque jour un rôle majeur
pour les enfants et leur devenir.
Une telle politique est forcément
interministérielle, tant elle
nécessite la mobilisation de tous
les ministères: l'Education
nationale, les ministères sociaux,
la Santé, la Justice, mais aussi
le Sport, la Culture, l'Emploi,
l'Enseignement supérieur.
Il faut toute une société pour
élever un enfant.
Hier, lors d'une commission autour
de l'enfant, vous avez participé à
la présentation de la réponse du
gouvernement en faveur de
l'enfant.
Je salue votre volonté d'actions en
faveur d'une vraie éducation quant
à la sexualité et à la
bienveillance.
Parmi vos réponses, il y a la
place de l'école, qui effectue une
véritable révolution dans vos
annonces, celle d'un soutien et de
la réussite pour des enfants
protégés.
L'école doit devenir
une bouée à laquelle les élèves
peuvent se raccrocher.
Mais 61% des adolescents de 15 ans
placés en établissement sont
toujours placés dans un niveau
relevant du premier cycle,
voire un niveau élémentaire.
Je ne parle même pas de tous ceux
qui quittent le système sans
diplôme.
Monsieur le ministre,
pourriez-vous détailler ce que
contient le nouveau dispositif de
scolarité protégée que vous avez
annoncé hier, pour que notre
République soit la chance des
enfants protégés demain?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gabriel
Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Madame la présidente Goulet, la
vulnérabilité a plusieurs visages.
Le rôle de l'Education nationale,
c'est d'accompagner tous les
enfants.
Nous étions réunis hier autour de
la Première ministre et de
Charlotte Caubel pour ce comité
interministériel à l'enfance.
Nous avons travaillé à la mise en
place d'une vraie scolarité
protégée pour les enfants qui sont
placés.
Cela signifie une simplification
de toutes les procédures
administratives pour lutter contre
le décrochage scolaire.
On sait que toutes les procédures
peuvent entraîner un certain
nombre de décrochages.
Après, ce sont des vulnérabilités
supplémentaires.
Ensuite, quand le décrochage
survient, la mise en place d'un
suivi renforcé est importante pour
leur permettre de poursuivre leur
scolarité.
Enfin, des entretiens
d'orientation seront
systématiquement mis en place pour
tous ces enfants, à la fin du
collège et à 17 ans.
Il faut que l'on soit plus
efficaces.
C'est insupportable, ce que vous
faites.
Brouhaha
Il y aura des référents désignés
pour coordonner l'action de tous
les acteurs.
C'est une mise en commun de tous
les acteurs pour renforcer toutes
ces mesures en faveur des enfants.
Les vulnérabilités peuvent
s'ajouter.
Malheureusement, on le voit.
Ce sont des enfants qui ont plus
de risques d'accumuler des
retards.
Nous devons être encore plus
impliqués pour leur permettre de
réussir.
Ils ont aussi le droit à l'école
de la République.
Ils ont le droit d'être ambitieux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Jaouen.
- Catherine Jaouen: Merci.
Madame la présidente,
mes chers collègues,
madame la ministre
déléguée chargée
des personnes
handicapées de France,
le 23 novembre
se tiendra la mise
en fonction d'une
plate-forme
que vous avez massivement
plébiscitée.
Pour vous,
la promotion de l'emploi
des personnes handicapées
est une priorité
du gouvernement.
Vous parlez de mesures fortes
pour accompagner
les personnes handicapées
vers l'emploi.
Mais qu'en est-il
au sein du ministère
de l'Education nationale?
Nous manquons de professeurs.
On peut s'interroger
sur le fait
que l'Education
nationale
ne remplisse pas ses quotas.
L'Education nationale
préfère s'acquitter
de pénalités auprès du fonds
pour l'insertion
des personnes
handicapées, au sein
de la fonction publique,
pour une somme
qui atteint les 31,8
millions d'euros.
L'Education nationale a dépensé
seulement 6,3 millions d'euros
en frais
de fonctionnement
pour son personnel
handicapé en 2022.
Le calcul est simple.
Cinq fois
plus d'argent dépensé
dans des pénalités
plutôt
que dans des investissements.
Vous avez poussé
les personnes handicapées
vers la sortie.
J'ai reçu une personne
agrégée récemment,
qui, suite à une maladie lourde,
a été orientée
vers le CNED: son handicap
physique s'est ensuite alourdi.
Elle souhaite pourtant
continuer à enseigner.
Le poste de travail
d'un fonctionnaire handicapé doit
être adapté,
selon la loi,
mais vous n'en faites rien.
Cette enseignante
a été mise au rebut
avec une retraite anticipée.
Comment pouvez-vous
prétendre faire
du handicap
une priorité nationale
et en même temps,
condamner les personnes
qui veulent travailler,
sous prétexte
de leur invalidité?
Que comptez-vous
faire pour répondre
au sous-emploi
des personnes handicapées
dans l'Education nationale?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Madame la députée
Catherine Jaouen,
l'Education nationale,
c'est le premier employeur
de France et d'Europe.
Cela lui donne d'immenses
responsabilités,
notamment en matière
d'inclusion
des personnes
en situation de handicap.
Est-ce que nous sommes au niveau
auquel
nous devrions
être dans l'Education nationale
s'agissant de l'accueil
des personnes
en situation de handicap?
Non.
Nous avons des agents
en situation
de handicap, près
de 40.000, au ministère
de l'Education nationale.
Ils sont aux côtés de nos élèves.
Nous devons
évidemment aller
plus loin et accueillir
davantage d'enseignants,
de personnels de santé,
de direction
et de personnels
administratifs en situation
de handicap.
On y travaille beaucoup,
avec mon collègue Stanislas
Guerini.
Ce que je peux vous dire
sur les actions
que nous avons engagées,
c'est que nous avons d'abord
développé une politique
ambitieuse d'allégement
de services et de postes adaptés.
Un professeur en situation
de handicap peut
se voir proposer
un service allégé
d'un tiers
tout en étant rémunéré
à temps complet.
C'est une possibilité
qui existe
et qui est déjà offerte
à un certain nombre d'enseignants.
Ensuite,
nous avons constitué
un réseau de conseillers
de proximité
et mis en place
des parcours professionnels
pour mieux accompagner
les évolutions professionnelles.
Il y a un plan quinquennal
qui a été constitué
pour aller
encore plus loin
dans la simplification
des démarches administratives
en 2027.
Vous l'avez dit,
certaines situations peuvent
être kafkaïennes.
Il faut tirer
des enseignements de cela.
Il y a encore beaucoup
à faire
dans la lutte
contre les discriminations
et l'accueil des personnes
en situation
de handicap.
Nous ne sommes pas au résultat
auquel
nous aimerions être,
mais nous y travaillons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Christine
Le Nabour.
- Christine Le Nabour: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à la ministre déléguée chargée
des Personnes handicapées.
La 27e édition
de la semaine européenne
pour l'emploi
des personnes handicapées
a débuté hier,
avec pour thématique,
la transition numérique,
un accélérateur
pour l'emploi
des personnes en situation
de handicap.
Permettez-moi de remercier
le ministre Olivier Dussopt
et son cabinet
pour leur travail
en faveur de l'emploi
pour les personnes
en situation de handicap.
17 mesures nouvelles
ont été annoncées,
dont certaines intégrées
dans le projet
de loi plein-emploi pour lequel
j'ai eu l'honneur
d'être co-rapporteur.
Ces textes visent à rendre
l'environnement professionnel
de droit commun
accessible
quel que soit le handicap.
Il favorise l'orientation
professionnelle.
Le taux de chômage
des personnes
en situation
de handicap est passé
à 12%.
Le nombre d'apprentis
a été multiplié
par 3.
C'est mieux, mais il reste
encore beaucoup
à faire.
L'événement
qui a lieu ce jeudi
et le temps fort de cette semaine.
Au cours de cette journée,
une entreprise,
une collectivité
ou une association peut accueillir
une personne
en situation de handicap
et former un duo
avec un professionnel volontaire.
Cela permet de créer
des vocations
et de faire naître
des opportunités.
Pouvez-vous nous rappeler
les mesures spécifiques prises
par le gouvernement
pour promouvoir l'emploi
des personnes
en situation de handicap?
Comment allez-vous
sensibiliser
les entreprises à ces questions?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Fadila Khattabi.
- Fadila Khattabi: Merci.
Madame la députée,
je tiens d'abord
à saluer l'ensemble
de votre travail
sur le sujet.
Vous l'avez rappelé,
l'importance
de la semaine européenne
pour l'emploi
des personnes
handicapées
que nous avons inaugurée
hier,
avec Olivier Dussopt,
au cours de laquelle
a lieu cette année le Duoday.
J'en profite pour saluer
la mobilisation
de l'ensemble des députés
pour la 6e édition
de cet événement.
C'est un événement très important.
Les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes.
26.360 duos sont confirmés
pour ce jeudi,
soit 27% de plus que l'année
dernière.
L'année dernière,
23% des candidats
qui sont passés
par le dispositif
ont eu une opportunité
professionnelle.
Cette journée est essentielle.
Elle contribue
à changer le regard
sur le handicap.
L'engagement
de notre gouvernement
va encore plus loin.
Avec mon collègue
Olivier Dussopt,
nous avons porté,
au travers du projet
de loi pour le plein
emploi
que vous avez voté hier,
des mesures concrètes
pour renforcer l'accompagnement
et l'insertion professionnelle
des personnes
en situation de handicap.
Ce qui prévaut désormais,
c'est le droit commun.
Ces personnes seront
toutes accompagnées
par le service
public de l'emploi
pour élaborer leur projet
professionnel,
tout en faisant l'avantage...
Cela favorisera davantage
les passerelles
vers le milieu ordinaire.
Nous aidons les entreprises
à se tourner
vers de nouvelles candidatures
qui correspondent
aux compétences
qu'elles recherchent,
notamment dans les métiers
en tension.
L'insertion dans l'emploi
passe aussi
par plus d'accessibilité,
notamment numérique.
Demain, on présentera
la ratification
des ordonnances
relatives à la mise
en accessibilité...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Louis Boyard.
- Louis Boyard:
Madame la présidente,
ce vendredi,
dans ma circonscription,
un homme a failli mourir.
Je l'ai eu au téléphone hier.
Voici ce qu'il m'a dit.
"Avant même de parler
de la souffrance
et du traumatisme
d'avoir reçu un coup
de cutter d'un centimètre
dans ma gorge
et après avoir subi
des insultes racistes,
cela fait trois jours
que j'ai subi
un crime raciste
et que personne
ne parle de moi.
Si moi, Mourad, j'avais
été l'agresseur,
BFMTV et CNews
auraient déjà été
en bas de ma maison."
Qu'est-ce que cela dit
de l'ambiance
qui règne dans notre pays?
Il ne se passe pas
une journée,
sans que dans
des débats télévisés,
on sous-entende
qu'il y a trop de musulmans
en France.
Il ne se passe pas
une journée
sans tout cela.
Cela fait des décennies
que votre classe politique épouse
les thèses
du Rassemblement National
et stigmatise
nos concitoyens qui vivent
en France,
travaillent en France
et qui ont le droit
à l'égalité en France.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur,
vous avez dit
que vous attendiez
de connaître la nationalité
des personnes
qui ont commis un meurtre
à Villecresnes
Vous, les ministres,
les macronistes,
les députés RN,
vos mots ont des conséquences.
Vos lois ont des conséquences.
Vous cultivez
les préjugés xénophobes
et les guerres de religion.
Bientôt arrive la loi immigration.
Vos mots auront des conséquences.
Quel est votre but?
Rassembler le pays ou le diviser?
Jusqu'où êtes-vous
prêts à aller
dans l'abject et dans la violence?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
En effet,
le 17 novembre,
dans votre département
d'élection,
un homme a été agressé.
Je suis là
pour protéger
toutes les personnes,
tous les policiers
et les gendarmes,
quelle que soit leur religion.
L'auteur est en effet
un Français
de 76 ans multirécidiviste.
Dégradations,
refus d'obtempérer,
outrages aux policiers...
Il a été interpellé
par les effectifs
de la BAC que vous voulez
supprimer,
par ailleurs.
Je remercie la police nationale.
Applaudissements
Oui, mesdames
et messieurs,
si l'on pouvait
regarder les personnes
pour ce qu'ils font
et non pas
pour ce qu'elles sont,
ni les définir
par leur race,
leur religion, leur prénom,
si on pouvait
simplement regarder
ceux qui respectent
les règles
de la République...
Si on pouvait attaquer
les récidivistes
à l'extrême gauche
comme à l'extrême droite,
si on pouvait,
du même mot, remercier
les policiers
quand ils arrêtent
ceux qui attaquent les juifs,
les musulmans,
les chrétiens, alors oui,
on aura apaisé
la situation.
Il n'y a que des hommes
qui doivent
être condamnés
pour ce qu'ils font.
Il n'y a que des Français
qui sont reconnus
par leur mérite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Une réponse?
- Louis Boyard:
Pour apaiser le pays,
cessez de vous comporter
comme un ministre
du Rassemblement National.
Huées
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Laurent Panifous.
Un peu de silence,
s'il vous plaît.
On écoute l'orateur.
Un peu de silence.
- Laurent Panifous: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs,
ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
des Solidarités
et des Familles.
Les soignants,
les personnes âgées
et les familles
nous alertent
sur la crise majeure
que traversent
nos EHPAD.
Le président
lui-même, au cours
des deux précédentes campagnes
présidentielles,
avait affiché
ses ambitions pour créer
les conditions
d'un accompagnement digne,
à domicile ou en établissement.
Il s'est engagé à porter
une réforme ambitieuse,
à la hauteur des attentes
des Français.
Une des mesures affirmées
par le président lui-même
était la création
de 50.000 postes
de soignants
en EHPAD avant la fin
du quinquennat.
C'est une réponse
très concrète
pour celles
et ceux qui vivent en EHPAD.
Les conditions
de travail en EHPAD
sont aussi très difficiles.
L'accompagnement
de nos aînés
les plus dépendants
n'est pas à la hauteur
de ce qu'attendent
nos concitoyens.
C'est pour cela
que l'engagement
de créer
entre six et sept postes
de soignants par EHPAD
est pertinent
et nécessaire.
Il faut donc former
plus de soignants,
mais aussi
redonner confiance
à toutes ces aides-soignants
et aides-soignantes,
ces infirmiers
et infirmières
qui ont quitté
le métier,
parce que c'était trop dur.
Nous pouvons le faire.
Il faut un choc de confiance.
Créer ces postes
est un choc de confiance.
J'ai lu une déclaration
qui laissait entendre
un report de cet
engagement du président
de la République.
Ce serait un renoncement.
Nous produisons
actuellement la loi
bien vieillir dans l'ombre
de la promesse
de la loi autonomie,
pouvez-vous
me dire que l'engagement
du président
de la République sera respecté?
Ces postes
seront-ils
créées avant la fin
du quinquennat?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Aurore Bergé.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs,
monsieur le député Panifous,
vous avez parlé
de confiance, donc
je vais reprendre vos termes.
C'est ce dont nous avons besoin
face
au défi démographique
de notre pays.
En 2030, un Français
sur trois aura
plus de 60 ans.
Toute la société
doit aujourd'hui
s'y adapter.
C'est le sens de la stratégie
interministérielle
que nous avons présentée
et de la proposition
de loi.
Nous avons travaillé
dans un climat précieux.
C'est le sens aussi
de l'engagement
que j'ai pris
avec la Première ministre
sur une loi
de programmation
sur le grand âge.
C'était quelque chose
d'attendu
par les parlementaires.
Vous le demandiez
et vous aviez raison
de le faire.
C'était aussi attendu
par les professionnels.
Cette loi de programmation
va permettre
de tracer des trajectoires
de financement,
sur la question
du grand âge,
et de trajectoires
en termes de recrutement
des professionnels.
Aujourd'hui,
les professionnels
sont dans une forme
de perte de sens
par rapport à leur métier.
Ce n'est pas les vocations
qui manquent.
C'est la manière
d'exercer le métier
qui pose problème.
La pénurie
de professionnels engendre
la pénurie de professionnels.
Cela met à mal
à la qualité de la prise
en charge des patients,
les bénéficiaires
et les résidents,
ainsi que le travail
professionnel.
Nous devons tenir
la trajectoire
que nous avons annoncée.
C'est notre responsabilité
pour garantir
que les EHPAD
puissent fonctionner.
700.000 personnes
qui y sont accompagnées doivent
également être prises en charge.
C'est pour cela que nous devons
faire
cette loi,
c'est pour cela
que nous devons donner
une trajectoire
de financement.
Il faut tenir
la trajectoire telle
qu'elle a été annoncée
par le président.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Mikaele Seo.
- Mikaele Seo: Merci.
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs,
je m'adresse au ministre
des Outre-mer
sur l'encadrement des habitants
de Wallis-et-Futuna.
Ils sont victimes d'erreurs
de communication.
Le seul moyen
de sortir
de chez eux est compliqué.
Des réquisitions
peuvent intervenir
à tout moment.
Les déplacements
des malades, des étudiants
et des administratifs
est périlleux.
Les collègues
qui viennent
jusque chez nous le constatent.
Il faut réserver
deux mois à l'avance
pour espérer avoir une place.
Le fret aérien est d'une
capacité ridicule.
Tant pour l'intérieur
de l'île
que pour l'extérieur.
Comment les producteurs
peuvent-ils exporter
et comment les produits
peuvent-ils
être importés?
Pourquoi
ne sommes-nous pas desservis
par des cargos?
Dans quelques jours,
un prestataire
de commerces de l'île va changer.
Que prévoyez-vous
pour garantir
à nos habitants
qu'ils ne soient
pas isolés à nouveau?
C'est tout une réflexion
nécessaire
à mener sur les moyens
de l'Etat
pour désenclaver Wallis-et-Futuna.
Nous avons besoin
de services adaptés,
de même pour les services
maritimes.
Deux pêcheurs viennent
de disparaître,
faute de capacité d'intervention.
Nous avons besoin
d'outils adaptés
à proximité.
Le gouvernement
est-il prêt à mettre
en place une vraie politique
de désenclavement aérienne
et maritime nécessaire
à la survie
de ces territoires?
Il faut mettre en place
une liaison maritime
pour les passagers
et les marchandises.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Vigier.
- Philippe Vigier: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Mikaele Seo, merci
de votre question
qui permet de rappeler
ce que fait
le gouvernement pour aider
le transport aérien.
300 millions d'euros
ont été apportés
ces trois dernières années
aux compagnies aériennes.
Concernant la desserte
de Wallis-et-Futuna,
vous savez très bien
qu'une délégation
de service public existe.
Le prestataire va changer
en janvier 2024.
C'est une autre
compagnie aérienne
qui va avoir cette charge.
Le gouvernement sera là
pour accompagner
cette transition.
Vous demandez ce que l'on fait.
On finance.
50%.
2,5 millions d'euros
pour cette délégation.
Wallis-et-Futuna
n'est pas oubliée.
Ensuite, vous parlez
des transports maritimes.
On a déjà échangé
sur cette question.
Cela est important
pour les passagers
mais aussi pour les marchandises.
Une étude
est actuellement en cours
au ministère.
Nous connaîtrons
le résultat
de cette étude à la fin
du premier trimestre 2024.
Pour le transport
aérien
et pour le transport
maritime,
nous sommes présents.
Au titre de la continuité
territoriale,
le soutien passera
de 70 millions
à 93 millions
d'euros en 2024,
pour payer une grande partie
des billets d'avion
pour celles
et ceux qui rentrent
de l'Hexagone
vers les territoires ultramarins.
Cela pourra aider
les étudiants boursiers
ou pas boursiers
à revenir
dans leur pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Je vais donner la parole
à monsieur Dino Cinieri.
Je voudrais lui rendre hommage.
C'est probablement
sa dernière question
au gouvernement.
Cela fait
plus de 20 ans
que vous êtes engagé
au service
de cette Assemblée
nationale et au service
de nos compatriotes.
Au nom de l'ensemble
de la représentation nationale,
je voudrais
vous remercier,
monsieur le député,
pour votre engagement
sans faille au service
des Français,
au sein de cette Assemblée
nationale.
Applaudissements
- Dino Cinieri: Merci.
Vos propos me vont droit au coeur.
Je profite
de cette dernière question,
après plus de 21
ans sur ces bancs,
pour vous remercier
pour le travail accompli ensemble,
de jours et parfois
de nuit, souvent
dans le respect,
malgré nos divergences.
Je mesure pleinement
la chance
qui a été la mienne
de siéger au sein
de cette noble
Assemblée, qui résonne
encore avec les voix
de Clemenceau, Jaurès,
Jacques Chirac et d'autres.
Ici, nous cherchons
toujours le meilleur
pour notre pays.
C'est ce qui doit nous animer.
Je tiens
à remercier aussi
tous les fonctionnaires,
les collaborateurs,
tous ceux qui travaillent
discrètement
dans cette belle maison
où j'ai été honoré
de servir mes concitoyens
du département
de la Loire.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur.
J'associe à ma question
l'ensemble
de mon groupe LR.
Je souhaite vous alerter
sur l'octroi
des trimestres
supplémentaires
pour les sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires,
pour le calcul de leur retraite.
Cette bonification
inscrite à l'article 24
de la loi du 14 avril 2023
est une reconnaissance importante
de l'engagement citoyen
des sapeurs-pompiers volontaires,
au service
de la collectivité
et vous me permettrez
aussi de susciter
des vocations.
Je veux le rappeler,
ils sont indispensables
dans le territoire.
Je tiens à leur rendre un hommage
particulier cet après-midi.
Un amendement sénatorial
adopté prévoyait
trois trimestres après 10
ans d'ancienneté,
complétés de trimestres
tous les 5 ans.
Mais la bonification
a été renvoyée
à un décret du Conseil d'Etat.
A ce jour,
le décret n'a
toujours pas été publié
au Journal officiel.
Pouvez-vous nous dire
quand ce décret sera pris?
Pouvez-vous nous confirmer
qu'il fixera
une majoration
de trois trimestres
après 10 ans d'ancienneté?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
permettez-moi également
de vous remercier
pour le travail
que vous avez apporté au sein
de l'Assemblée nationale.
J'ai été témoin,
pour être votre collègue,
et ministre, de vos apports
toujours sérieux.
Votre circonscription
vous a toujours réélu,
vous étiez très populaire.
Je souhaite aussi
la bienvenue
à votre suppléante
qui va vous remplacer.
Je connais
votre engagement
pour les sapeurs-pompiers
depuis longtemps.
Je veux vous rassurer.
Il s'agit d'une disposition
qui a été votée
dans l'article 24
du projet de loi
de financement
de la Sécurité sociale,
qui prévoit des trimestres
supplémentaires
dans le cadre
que vous avez évoqué
pour les sapeurs-pompiers.
Evidemment, ce décret
va être pris.
Vous avez continûment
porté ces mesures
pour les sapeurs-pompiers.
Je crois qu'elles ont été
adoptées.
L'exonération des charges
pour les employeurs
des sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires a été acceptée.
Il y a aussi
la nouvelle prestation
de fidélisation
et de reconnaissance,
qui aujourd'hui,
n'est pas adaptée,
que vous avez souvent revendiquée.
C'est donc plein
du devoir accompli
que vous pouvez désormais quitter
l'Assemblée nationale.
Encore merci
pour votre soutien
pour les sapeurs-pompiers
et pour les agents
du ministère de l'Intérieur.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Cette séance des questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.